[Music]
[Music]
hey what's up guys it's Robin welcome to
my tutorial for the I'm gonna have some
top comments that you guys left me in
the last video at the end of this
tutorial so be sure to check them out if
you do wind up liking this video be sure
to give it a big thumbs up below and
subscribe and push the notification bell
so you get all notifications from my
channel here's Leela for those of you
who are wondering the super compass star
is a very simple eight-pointed ninja
star that is made up of four modular
units this is definitely one of the
easiest ninja stars that I ever made
I'll show you how you can make a big one
and a small one but the small one flies
a lot better so I would recommend using
this one if you're going to throw it I'm
going to be using red and blue printer
paper just like this but you can use any
colors you like
so grab your paper and let's get started
1 square will make two modular units so
grab one sheet and take the upper right
corner and align the top edge with the
left side edge once the two edges are
aligned make crease all the way
throughout flip the paper over and fold
the top edge down until the folded edge
meets up what that edge we just fold it
on the other side then crease it with
your fingernail and tear the excess
paper off now we're going to tear the
paper along this diagonal line so we
could fold the paper in the opposite
direction increase it and now we just
have to make a small tear at the corner
here and then we could tear both pieces
apart now you're going to have two
triangles and we just need one to make
one of the module units to make the
smaller modular unit we're just going to
take this corner and fold the paper in
half to meet this corner just like this
if you're going to make the smaller
ninja star this is the piece of paper
that you're going to start with to make
the module unit we're going to take both
of these edges here and fold them down
on to the bottom edge here we'll start
out by doing the right side so take the
right edge here and we're going to fold
it down onto the bottom edge
once this edge meets with this edge like
this then we can make a crease you don't
necessarily have to crease it all the
way up here but I'm going to do it
because it makes things a little bit
easier so don't really crease it too
hard towards the top here but crease it
all the way through like that then you
can open it up and do the same with this
side and then you can make a crease so
when you open up the paper you should
have something that looks just like this
you're going to need to pop this out
here what we're going to do is we're
going to first fold these two edges down
onto the bottom edge like this then
we're going to walk our fingers up to
the middle here we're actually going to
bring these two edges together grab
these two edges and you're going to make
sure that this becomes a point right
there so you want to basically fold
these two edges until they touch each
other like this then just crease it down
until you get down to this edge right
here of the paper again I just took the
two edges I folded them down and walk my
fingers up until I had that point and
made sure that these two edges were
aligned so it's gonna look something
like this now I'm going to take these
two points and I'm going to fold them
down like this and I'm going to make
sure that these two tips line up so hold
it there in place with your right hand
and then you could basically just crease
all the way up to this corner and you
also want to crease here in the middle
so just hold it there and just kind of
flatten your hand out and smooth it out
and there you go that's how to make one
of the modular units if we open up the
modular unit you'll see that these two
are Valley folds the middle point to the
top is also a valley fold
however the bottom edge here to the
middle point is a mountain fold so it
closes just like this just remember with
a smaller unit you do have two layers
here but you have to kind of pretend
that they're glued together okay
same thing edge edge down to the bottom
edge so fold the right edge down to the
bottom in crease through
and fold the left edge down to that
bottom edge increase the right and left
edges go down to the bottom and then
make sure that the top two edges are
touching while you make that point and
crease it all the way down to the center
then you could just flatten everything
out and you should have something that
looks like this now we can make the
other three module units same thing edge
to edge and then you can just fold it
down and pinch the top flatten it out do
the same thing with the other two I just
want you to put the four pieces just
like this so that the bottom corner is
in the bottom-left side of the whole
entire piece so it looks like a check
right the bottom edge looks like a check
now we're going to add them in
sequential order like this so it's going
to be the blue is going to add to this
one red to this one and then the blue to
this one okay each consecutive piece is
going to be 90 degrees clockwise to the
last piece starting out with this one if
you look at this top edge it's flat this
one's flat in the same position so this
one has to go 90 degrees clockwise like
this now the next piece is going to be
90 degrees clockwise to this one's
position so if we put it in that ones
position and then spin it 90 degrees
clockwise just like this this edge will
be facing to the bottom the opposite of
what this one is now we're just rotating
them so this is the last piece so it's
basically going to be 90 degrees
clockwise to the last pieces position
that one so it's going to look like this
and then we're gonna spin at 90 degrees
clockwise so that's going to be the
position of the pieces in order to join
them let's start with the first two here
we'll take this one when you're adding a
piece the piece that you're adding the
tips are going to go on the outside of
the last pieces blast so these tips are
going to go on the outside of the red
ones let's you take the red one slide it
in here and just make sure that this
flat edge when you lift it up it's gonna
stop right there at the corner because
of this little inside pocket here so
just bring it up to the top and then you
could slide the blue piece to the left
until it stops right along this crease
that we made remember that there's a
crease right here and that corner is
gonna stop right on the end
now we're going to join the red piece
the next red piece and remember when
you're doing it the flaps of the piece
you're joining are going to go on the
outside of the last piece so just put it
like this on the blue piece both of the
flaps go on the outside of the blue
pieces flaps like this and now this flat
edge is going to get stopped right at
this corner and then you get to slide it
up like that now the last piece looks
like this
alright the corners on the bottom right
like that last piece you're adding a
piece so the flaps are going to go on
the outside of the last piece you just
added right here like that
however the tips need to go on the
inside of the first piece okay so it
needs to go over the last piece into the
first piece so what I like to do
basically just open this up a little bit
to make it easier for yourself like that
and now I would hold it on the last one
like this and then the flaps go on the
outside of the red piece into the other
red piece just like this okay so that's
the top one now flip it over and you're
gonna do the same on this side and now
once the both tips are in remember it
looks just like this you just slide them
through and then push everything
together I would just take the tips on
one end and take the opposite tips and
pull them and then do the same with the
blue tips just pull them like that
alright so so everything is not joined
up yet it's sliding alright you might
have a similar issue but what we're
going to do now just hold everything
nice and firm in the middle here like
this we're going to take the top flap
alright the top flap of the two and
we're going to crease it along the edge
here like this
crease it make a crease and then you're
going to unfold it and you're going to
tuck it into this pocket so just bend it
tuck it into the pocket along that
crease that we made and then close it so
now only one of these tips is going to
be sticking out of that
and then just do the same here the top
tip goes on the edge you fold it and
then you tuck it into the red pocket
then you take the red tip fold it onto
the blue edge and then you tuck it into
the blue pocket blue goes down and then
you tuck it into the red one and there
you go once you're done is flatten
everything out and if you hold it like
this so the two points are north and two
points are east and west it looks like a
compass rose north east south west north
east south east south west and north
west
stars throwing it like I said the bigger
one doesn't fly as well as the smaller
ones if you hold it like this with the
pocket facing towards you
that's about the best that'll do but
this one you can either flick it like a
frisbee or throw it over a hand it
doesn't really matter
ooh not bad thank you guys so much for
the support and I hope you enjoyed the
video so I kind of want to switch it up
for my next tutorial do you guys want to
see how to make a boomerang that flies
like this or maybe had a jungle or I
could show you how to make a great
guacamole or possibly some abstract art
that's really cool let me know leave me
a comment in the comment section and
whoever gets the highest thumbs up I'll
do that tutorial now you can give Leela
a treat hey sweetheart
you haven't seen you in a while here's a
treat Leela